[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP très heureuse
de vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
saison sur la chaîne parlementaire et
pour bien commencer l'année il ne mange
pas de viande mais il va passer sur le
grill notre invité est aymeric Caron
bonjour et bienvenue et pour vous
cuisiner avec moi Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte
bonjour aymeric Caron bonjour
Jean-Pierre alors vous êtes député la
France insoumise depuis le mois de juin
dernier vous êtes un homme engagé
parce que je suis dans le groupe
français
on y arrive pardon vous êtes donc un
homme engagé comme la thèse votre
carrière vous avez débuté dans le
journalisme vous avez travaillé pour
tous les grands groupes de médias TF1
Europe 1 grand reporter à Canal+ vous
avez été envoyé au Kosovo en Afghanistan
en Irak en Tchétchénie en Israël enfin
bon un bon CV pour accéder au Parlement
dans un contexte de majorité relative on
vous retrouve bien plus tard sur France
2 dans On n'est pas couché où vous
croisez le faire avec BHL à l'infinal
Croates ou Caroline forest mais c'est en
2018 que votre engagement politique se
matérialise véritablement avec la
création de votre mouvement rêve donc
pour révolution écologique pour le
vivant vous vous dites anarchiste et
vous prenez la désobéissance civile
militant de l'écologie radicale
antispéciste vegan vous êtes l'auteur
entre autres de nostek ce qui nous donne
une piste pour le menu du jour
ni deux au menu mais un grand bol comme
en Asie j'allais dire avec du tofu des
champignons noirs et des nouilles de riz
et on desserre une mousse au chocolat
mais attention vegan dans le dessous des
plats jamais sans mon barbecue côte de
bœuf merguez les adeptes de la grillade
nous disent pourquoi ils sont si
attachés à ce rendez-vous culinaire dans
les pieds dans plat arrow sur les Dark
store ces magasins fantômes qui
empoisonnent la vie des riverains les
pouvoirs publics entendent faire le
ménage enquête à suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
aymeric Caron robinant votre carrière
riche et éclectique de journaliste j'ai
bien identifié quelques sujets de
complicité à partager à table comme vos
années de grands reporters sur tous les
fronts ou encore votre passage chez
Ruquier pour nous raconter les coulisses
croustillantes de la télé mais en
revanche question menu à partager à
évidence on en a pas dormi avec Brigitte
elle a même alerté un traiteur au cas où
nous auriez obligé à croquer des
sauterelles grillées pour sauver la
planète alors après l'écologie punitive
sommes-nous bon pour la gastronomie
punitive disons finalement Brigitte on
s'en sort pas trop mal avec une sorte de
bo-bun qui porte mal son nom puisqu'il
n'y a pas de boeuf beau ni de crevettes
d'ailleurs ni deux sinon vous êtes bien
capable de déserter ce plateau mais on
va donc se rabattre sur le tofu et là on
est sauvé car au moins d'un point de vue
gustatif se totem de la cuisine vegan ce
fromage de soja a disons un goût
inimitable puisque justement il en a pas
c'est ça votre conception des plaisirs
de la table et bricaron ça débute
le tofu c'est vrai que d'ailleurs la
première fois que j'ai mangé du tofu
c'était en Chine où je faisais mon
service civil pendant deux ans j'avais
une vingtaine d'années et c'est
effectivement un copain qui me dit à
l'époque j'étais végétarien Pagan donc
mais tiens je vais te faire découvrir le
tout et vraiment ma première pression a
été de manger de la lessive donc je lis
mais c'est quoi aujourd'hui mais
justement comme je suis passé par là
avant vous je peux vous rassurer en fait
ce que j'ai pas compris non c'est pas ça
du tout c'est qu'en fait ça a pas de
goal tofu alors là il avait accusé d'une
manière un petit peu particulière parce
que aussi le goût c'est très subjectif
ce qui se passe aussi vous le savez très
bien c'est que nous sommes habitués il y
a une éducation au goût donc nous sommes
habitués à manger certaines choses et
apprécier certains goûts et à être
rebutés par d'autres qui en réalité si
on avait été éduqué autrement nous
conviendrait très bien et donc il y a
des cuisines qui sont nouvelles pour
nous et il faut qu'on s'y habitué un
petit peu donc si par exemple vous
mangez des
à l'époque j'en mangeais maintenant j'en
mangeais des œufs de 100 ans
je pense que beaucoup de Français vont
détester peut-être Jean-Pierre vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est enfin
vous voyez ce que c'est des autres mais
c'est fermenté etc
ils sont tout noir ils ont été très
longtemps etc alors beaucoup de gens
détestent parce que c'est une odeur
extrêmement forte quasiment d'ammoniaque
un goût d'ammoniaque ça et moi j'adorais
à l'époque le goût c'est je vais
demander à un chinois puisque c'est
voilà j'ai vécu là-bas donc j'ai un peu
des expériences justement de comparaison
culinaire j'avais une amie chinoise la
première fois qui venus en France la
première fois que elle était devant un
plateau de fromage vraiment les plateaux
fromage foncé le camembert le fin tout
ce que vous pouvez imaginer elle a des
tests et il y avait marche pas ou soit
on est aujourd'hui parce que moi ça
commence à dater tout ça je suis plus
jeune mais il y a 25 ans il y avait en
Chine les fromages qui commençaient à
arriver parce que les Chinois n'étaient
pas habitués du tout aux produits
laitiers parce que l'élevage de vaches
tout ça pas été du tout le truc de la
Chine pendant longtemps et puis leur
fromage on en parlera mais c'était le
tofu alors ouais absolument ça le
remplace mais
dommage que vous pouviez trouver c'était
des fromages sans goût c'est des pâtes
comme ça un peu insipides parce que il
n'était pas habitué donc voilà et le
tofu pourrait revenir
c'est que le tofu en fait ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que on ne le
connais pas en France c'est à dire que
si vous avez dans votre magasin vous
achetez effectivement votre plaquette de
tofu je vais pas citer la marque mais le
truc classique là qui existe depuis
10-15 ans vous mettez ça dans votre
assiette ça n'a aucun goût effectivement
ça rebute tout le monde bien évidemment
ce qui fait la seule autofu d'abord
c'est la manière la le truc qui a été la
pâte a été faite parce que il y a plein
de sortes de pattes de tout
et puis ensuite bien évidemment c'est la
sauce c'est l'accompagnement
l'assaisonnement des plats véganes et
les petites herbes aussi peut-être les
coriandre là notamment bien sûr par
exemple
ce qui est génial avec le tofu vous
achetez un Tofu alors un sous ce qu'on
appelle soyeux Hu de sésame Coriandre et
puis un peu de sel voilà que ça et bah
c'est super bon en Chine j'ai mangé dans
des restaurants végétariens ou ont
trouvé des dizaines de formes et
d'accommodation du tofu différente avec
par exemple un Tofu qui imite le canard
laqué bien évidemment
c'est pas vraiment un canard vous mangez
et c'est la sauce là encore qui fait
tout toute la saveur
la texture est très importante c'est le
restaurant Le Petit taille qui nous a
donné ce plat c'est pas vous qui l'avez
fait non et c'est quoi cette histoire
vous savez que la cuisine asiatique je
veux pas je veux pas titiller mais en
principe façon avec des baguettes quand
même exactement là on en a pas non alors
parce que c'était c'est un resto taille
et les tailles fournissent pas toujours
des baguettes parce qu'en Thaïlande on
peut manger avec des fourchettes et des
couteaux ah bon on peut aussi en Chine
Brigitte alors Jean-Pierre trois choses
à savoir
sur mes trois choses à savoir sur le
tofu le tofu est donc disons-le un
fromage de soja comme la sauce du même
nom ou le miso c'est donc un produit
dérivé de cette plante herbacée de la
famille de la famille des légumineuses
voilà pourquoi ça plaît à notre ami
vegan ne tofu s'obtient par le caillage
du lait de soya suivi d'une étape
dégoutage puis de pressage et
effectivement c'est c'est cette chaîne
là est très importante aymeric Caron l'a
rappelé deux le tofu se consomme
attention crue ou cuit comme il n'a
quasiment pas de goût on vient de dire
il est meilleur mariné ou cuisine dans
une sauce ou dans un bouillon il peut
être grillé frit ou même cuit en
brouillade pour remplacer des œufs ça
c'est un bon exemple parmi ces atouts en
cuisine parce que c'est pour ça que
c'est intéressant aussi le tofu c'est
pour ça que les Chinois le consomment il
est riche en protéines végétales en
calcium et très faible en matière grasse
attention le tofu est un fromage donc il
est périssable conserver le bien au
réfrigérateur voire simulateur car il
peut se congeler et si le tofu devient
visqueux ou dégage une mauvaise odeur ne
le manger surtout pas le tofu est foutu
je vous confirme
-moi est très bon c'est quoi le
restaurant qui l'a amené je pouvais être
très heureux de votre commande
est très bon vous n'avez c'est ce qu'on
se disait
une petite sauce avec du Niort avec du
citron vert qui fait que ça relève un
petit peu par exemple un restaurant
chinois formidable le pays de Confucius
dans le 13e il faut un Tofu mais ils le
font cuire dans une sauce pimentée
parce qu'on mange cette sauce pimentée
effectivement vous faisiez allusion
aussi à la sauce du canard laqué
effectivement c'est très bon ça peut
être très bon mais c'est la sauce qui
fait tout dans le tofu absolument et la
texture et la texture alors il y a aussi
ce vin qu'on vous a proposé qu'il y a un
vin biologique et vegan c'est ce que
vous nous aviez demandé évidemment vegan
alors c'est un vin de la région du
Minervois elle a mis les hym 2020 et
c'est des cépages Syrah et Grenache
c'est assez fruité je sais pas s'il est
à votre goût peut-être un mot pour les
téléspectateurs entre 20 bio et 20 vegan
parce que c'est tous posé la question
que vous m'avez tous demandés ce qu'elle
était la différence en gros en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que dans la
fabrication du vin il y a une technique
qui s'appelle le collage et qui consiste
à mettre en fait du blanc d’œuf pour
récupérer toutes les particules qui sont
en suspension sur le vin d'autres choses
il y a pas beaucoup
de poissons
et donc ça ça permet de clarifier le vin
mais dans les vins vegan on en met pas
effectivement on va utiliser un procédé
végétal là encore ou rien du tout enfin
on met rien parce que c'est un peu un
état d'esprit non être végan c'est un
état d'esprit après on peut être vegan
pour plein de raisons on peut l'être
pour quelle raison alors quel était le
déclic vous avez dit sept ans 30 ans de
végétarien et sept ans le déclic
alors ce qui est alors un déclic ce qui
est très bizarre c'est que moi je me
pose la question je suis toujours que
j'ai toujours été je suis né
antispéciste alors tout part de là c'est
pour ça je vous dis qu'on peut être
vegan par philosophie et c'est mon cas
c'est à dire l'antispéciste considère
que on ne doit pas discriminer un être
vivant en raison de son espèce on doit
pas considérer autrement un être vivant
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut traiter tous
les animaux de la même manière ça veut
pas dire qu'on veut donner le droit de
vote aux vaches ça veut dire simplement
que si on considère par exemple que si
on découpe un avis un cochon ça lui fait
mal comme ça nous ferait mal à nous
humains on le fait pas voilà c'est ça ça
veut dire ça veut dire aussi que si on
peut laisser vivre cet animal comme nous
on souhaiterait vivre et bien laissons
le vivre donc on s'interroge à ce que
c'est vraiment nécessaire de le tuer ou
pas donc quand on voit qu'on peut se
passer en effet de tuer un animal et
bien on s'en passe donc les sauterelles
que je vous ai proposé pareil vous ne
les auriez pas mangé si j'ai pas besoin
non si j'ai besoin oui mais si je suis
dans une situation
voilà de survivre et donc et donc juste
pour donc j'ai toujours eu en fait voilà
ce sentiment qui me liait aux animaux
depuis que je suis d'aussi loin
que je ne peux pas expliquer
c'est-à-dire que je voyais des animaux
je ne trouvais pas normal qu'on les
mange je voyais un animal en cage ça me
faisait énormément de chagrin quand
j'étais enfant je ne supportais pas ça
bon vous avez jamais emmené aux autres
mais venu après ce qui s'est passé c'est
que comme on est là encore le fruit
d'une éducation et que mes parents
étaient certes écologistes mais qu'ils
étaient comme tout le monde ils manger
de la viande et ainsi de suite il me dit
non non mais ça fait partie de la vie
c'est normal on mange des animaux ils
sont pas malheureux ils sont bien
traités etc j'ai eu plusieurs déclics
premier déclic à 12 ans on va en
vacances à la ferme
on va chercher le lait le soir il y a là
des petits agneaux qui viennent de
naître et je demande aux agriculteur
évidemment je les trouve adorable ils me
font penser à mes chats à mes chiens oh
là là ils sont trop mignons voilà
qu'est-ce qui va et là il me dit ah bah
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont devenir je demande
la question il me dit on va les tuer
bien sûr je et et là ça me fait manger
ça me fait un choc parce que ta coup je
pense à l'agneau que je mange le
dimanche et j'ai 12 ans chez ma
grand-mère ma grand-mère faisait un
agneau le dimanche et j'y pense tout de
suite et là je fais le lien donc j'ai ok
j'arrête de manger ça et donc je vais
commencer par arrêter de manger c'est
pas possible là je viens de voir
l'animal et après il y a encore quelques
années où je vais continuer à manger des
mains en diminuant mais toujours avec
l'idée qu'on m'avait raconté que les
animaux ils avaient quand même une belle
vie avant de mourir voilà il y avait
toujours été et là je vais tomber bien
avant L214 sur des images alors je sens
enfin le jour devient génétarien je
deviens végétarien je suis chez moi j'ai
une vingtaine d'années il y a le journal
de d'Antenne 2 à l'époque journal de la
nuit
je crois que c'était Philippe le fait
qui le présente vous voyez comme il y a
des moments marquants dans la vie je me
souviens encore de où j'étais
actuellement et là il dit voilà on va
montrer des images qui se passent dans
un abattoir et c'est une vache qu'ils
prennent comme ça qui accroché à la par
la pâte à un crochet suspendu en l'air
la grue bouge légèrement relâche la
vache qui tombe par terre et avec des
soubresauts et puis d'autres images du
même genre et ce jour-là je dis assez ça
la vérité de la manière dont on traite
les animaux donc ils sont abattus c'est
terminé je ne mangerai plus jamais de
viande de ma vie donc voilà ensuite
c'est devenu quelque chose de
d'extrêmement présent dans mon quotidien
mais à chaque fois ça a été en fait une
confrontation avec la réalité parce que
je suis persuadé que si aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de gens qui mangent encore de
la viande c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
tout à fait conscience de ce qui se
passe réellement dans les élevages et
dans les abattoirs et votre alimentation
elle est assez variée vous avez le choix
parce que souvent quand on va au
restaurant on ouvre la carte et puis il
y a on mange toujours un peu la même
chose vous vous avez des adresses
j'imagine oui la chance que j'ai c'est
que le depuis 10 ans il y a quand même
une énorme évolution sur sur ces
questions donc aujourd'hui un vegan peut
se nourrir assez facilement au
restaurant en choisissant les bonnes
adresses évidemment
il y a aussi une compréhension de plus
en plus grande des restaurateurs
c'est-à-dire que même quand la carte ne
propose pas forcément une notion vegan
il est possible de discuter je viens
quand même d'un temps ou être végétarien
était un problème énorme lorsqu'on est
le restaurant où les gens me rayonnaient
il y a encore 20 ans ou 15 ans même
j'allais dans un restaurant machiste et
quel ordre j'ai lu ça dans un papier sur
vous ah ça c'est autre chose oui mais ça
c'est deux choses c'est ça c'est une
question qui se disait des tips il
disait mais tu manges pas de viande mais
c'est pour un homme c'est pas possible
il y a pas de problème quand on a un
homme et comment je fais de viande enfin
voilà des trucs comme ça qui était
effectivement assez obscurantistes donc
je pouvais dans un resto où il y avait
pas d'option végétarienne prévue je suis
végétarien de m'entendre dire il y a
encore du saga végétarien c'est quoi ce
truc là voilà donc avec une forme de
mépris
parce que dans le même temps je
voyageais beaucoup et je savais que par
exemple en Chine évidemment c'était
extrêmement simple en Australie en
Angleterre enfin il y a des tas de pays
où ça me posait aucun problème bah on a
évidemment je pense aussi ils étaient en
avance par rapport à nous certaines
villes un pas tout il y a des il y a des
New York San Francisco enfin il y a des
bases comme ça
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollables
alors Aymeric car on vous le fan de BD
j'ai lu ça aussi et l'ex grand reporter
vous devez être un collable sur les
aventures de Tintin dans quel album
Tintin se fait-il servir un plat
intitulé slasheq aux champignons ah le
crabe au pince d'or B le spectre de
tocard c'est Linois des Tintins au Tibet
alors je veux dire la vérité avant
pardon je vais peut-être un peu long
Tintin ça jamais été trop ma tasse de
thé moi j'étais très Astérix et Gaston
Lagaffe cette question sur Tintin alors
vu le nom le vu le nom je vais dire
Tintin au Tibet et ben non le spectre
d'autocar parce qu'il s'agit d'un gigot
de jeunes chiens à la sauce sildave et
vous savez que dans le spectre d'autocar
on est en Sylvie et j'ai retrouvé
l'album et c'est assez drôle quand le le
serveur dit que c'est un gigot de chien
Tintin est épouvanté parce qu'il pense
qu'il vient de manger Milou Milou à la
cartouche d'après Milou apparaît
vous êtes également natif de Boulogne
vous êtes donc un habitué de la crier
est-ce que vous seriez nous dire
[Rires]
quel poisson parmi ces quatre n'est pas
un poisson plat à la barbue
c'est la seule et des le padre rouge bon
la sole c'est très plat ça je le
confirme
la barbue alors
la Barbie c'est la cousine du turbo son
plat c'est le pagre rouge
ce sera plus simple
je suis pas du tout un spécialiste des
poissons c'est pas parce que je suis né
donc forcément le quiz j'ai mangé
beaucoup de sol quand j'ai mangé ceci
dit non c'est vrai que enfant jusqu'à ce
que j'ai mangé énormément de sol oui
alors on sait qu'en France le repas
occupe une assez large place et c'est
souvent autour d'un bon repas que ce
nous des amitiés que se racontent les
meilleures histoires alors c'est la
brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé aymericatement
de réfléchir à une histoire une anecdote
autour d'un repas est-ce que il y en a
une qui vous est revenue à l'esprit mais
oui j'ai un grand moment de gênant
qui me ramène aux années où j'étais
végétarien mais où c'était pas du tout
quelque chose qui était habituel et
j'habitais donc en CHINE à Shanghai je
travaille pour le consulat de France à
Shanghai et puis je suis invité un jour
chez le consul qui donne un repas
officiel donc repas officiel dans un
consulat vous imaginez une très grande
table bien plus grande que celle-ci qui
pourtant est déjà très grande
énorme table avec une dizaine de
personnes seulement repas très
solennelle et à l'époque je suis
végétarien il faut savoir que je vais
vivre une période comme ça pour me
disait d'année où c'est très gênant
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est accepté c'est
très commun même aujourd'hui mais il y a
encore 20 ou 30 ans être végétarien
c'était quelque chose de considéré
quasiment comme anormal il fallait
quasiment s'excuser d'être Végéta et
donc à ce moment là je sais pas comment
me comporter quand j'étais invité
quelque part société quand j'étais
invité c'est à dire est-ce qu'il fallait
ou non prévenir la personne qui vous
invitait que vous ne mangiez pas de
viande donc généralement je disais rien
pour pas me faire remarquer et donc je
ne dis rien je vais à ce repas je vais
sauf que qu'est-ce qui se passe on nous
sert à tous une assiette dans laquelle
il y a une petite caille et à 4 ou 5
petits pois à côté et le c'est un repas
officiel avec des dignités chinois mais
il y a pas voilà c'est pas une ambiance
de folie il y a beaucoup de silence et
quand les les assiettes sont amenés
il y a encore là en conscience et tout
le monde est très content d'avoir son
essai qui arrive pour pouvoir commencer
à manger ça occupe au moins l'espace et
moi je ne peux pas manger parce que je
m'étais dit je crois je ferais semblant
je mettrai la petite viande de côté non
il y a pas de il y a rien de l'autre
côté il y a 4 petits pois donc il y a
que la caille et donc
je suis un jeune en plus arrivé dans le
consulat enfin vraiment et donc je lui
qu'est-ce que je fais parce que tout le
monde commence à voir que je ne mange
pas donc tout le monde est en train de
manger puis moi je suis comme ça comme
là avec les bras croisés j'ai mis
qu'est-ce que je ne peux pas me forcer
donc je dis trop fort impossible
je ne pouvais pas y toucher c'était
c'était non non c'est pas possible donc
j'étais obligé de faire une espèce
d'annonce officielle
en m'excusant de ne pas toucher au plat
en expliquant je ne mangeais pas de
viande ce qui ce qui était extrêmement
gênant mais ce qui paradoxalement
apparemment a détendu tout le monde dans
ce repas puisqu'ils avaient trouvé un
sujet de conversation parce que pendant
les 30 minutes qui ont un suivi c'est
mais pourquoi mais comment mais voilà
quelle histoire voilà mais à partir de
là j'ai décidé donc en effet je n'avais
pas à m'excuser de manger un peu
différemment des autres et au contraire
ben voilà qu'il fallait m'en expliquer
ça m'a un peu décomplexé du coup parce
que voilà je ne sais pas si c'est une
anecdote qui va rester dans les annales
de l'émission mais c'est la somme que
j'ai trouvé dans le temps à partir et
alors quand vous êtes entre amis et tout
ça j'imagine que vos amis vous
connaissent bien ils font ils font
attention mais quand vous rencontrez des
gens qui ne savent pas forcément vous
êtes invités à dîner ça peut poser des
des problèmes parfois c'est un peu
gênant c'est l'avantage que j'ai il faut
bien le dire honnêtement c'est que
maintenant il y a pas il y a pas un ami
qui ignore que je suis végétarien enfin
vegan maintenant donc quand
vous invite pas c'est ça et sinon il
m'invite pas ils savent non je vous
expliquer ce à quoi j'assis c'est ce qui
est quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire par rapport au premier
livre que j'ai sorti sur le sujet notek
il y a près de 10 ans
c'est qu'il y a un inversement c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est
quasiment si vous avez une tablette avec
6-7 personnes il y en a au moins allez 3
4 voir 5 qui sont végétariennes ou en
tout cas qui ne mange quasiment pas de
viande et on arrive à un stade où
aujourd'hui finalement c'est la personne
qui arrive et qui mange la viande qui
est excusez-moi je mange la viande
oui c'est peut-être pas dans tous les
foyers français mais vous n'êtes pas un
taliban vous allez acheter des copains
ou certains mangent de la viande et
partager la vidéo autour de vous le
fumet d'une cuit mais bien sûr ça c'est
vraiment une c'est drôle d'ailleurs même
dans mon équipe à l'Assemblée il y en a
qui qui souhaitaient qui disent par
exemple mon directeur de cabinet mais tu
travailles avec 40 mais tu es végane
alors disons je suis absolument pas
végane mais je demande pas à quelqu'un
même qui va travailler avec moi ce qui
mange je m'en moque complètement et je
je mange bien évidemment avec tout le
monde on va en parler on n'a pas fini de
parler de la vie on a Jean-Pierre on va
parler même du barbecue qui symbolise le
virilisme c'est ce que votre ami
Sandrine Rousseau alors pas seulement
apparemment celle de sous des plaintes
en tout cas
[Musique]
détrives des saucisses de la viande
rouge tout y passe le barbecue ou la
plancha sont autant de manières de cuire
car rendez-vous amical et convivial
alors dans le Sud-Ouest est impensable
de s'en passer et quand les grillades
ont lieu en marge d'une feria là c'est
carrément de la provoc pour notre invité
reportage dans les Landes de Maël Morin
je suis en train de cuire le côte
d'agneau ça vient de Pays Basque et puis
après je le du gros sel du poivre et du
thym et je les mets au chaud au
bain-marie
au pied des arènes on entend moins les
vivas du public que les crépitements de
la viande qui cuit sur le green
n'attend pas on a commencé à servir les
tripes des 8 heures du matin puis au
tour des grillades en tout genre je
prépare des andouillettes ça c'est des
du jambonneau c'est des talons de jambon
là
je suis en train de le préparer des
cœurs de canard mais on les dégraisse
sur les coupes en deux et on les met sur
des brochettes
1800 coeurs de canard préparés en deux
jours 150 jambonneau des centaines
d'andouillettes dans ces beaux dégâts
ces petits bistrot du sud de la France
ne pas servir de viande est impensable
la majorité des gens qui viennent faire
la fête leur peau leur petit coin de
viande pour vous tenir parce que
quand on fait la fête pendant toute la
nuit avant il faut quand même prendre
des forces même les gosses
c'est amusant pour eux c'est dans les
mœurs c'est la viande au viande non
c'est comme si on enlève l'alcool c'est
pareil
manger de la viande c'est une tradition
de ces fêtes du Sud-Ouest et pour les
spectateurs de tauromachi Venus déjeuner
difficile de s'en passer chez moi il y a
jamais eu un repas sans oublier
nos viandes ici l'urgence climatique n'a
pas encore réussi à bouleverser les
habitudes
végétarien ou de ne plus manger bien bon
après on sera certainement obligé
réduire notre ration de
viande mais je pense que c'est dans les
mains ici certains c'est parce que ils
peuvent tout simplement pas manger de la
viande ça les équerres d'autres c'est
pas principe mais je vois pas pourquoi
on devrait imposer ce pays là aux autres
après chacun fait comme il veut et
chacun mange ce qu'il veut dans son
assiette sous le chapiteau on apprécie
les dernières grillades de la saison et
il faudra attendre que le printemps
redonne le top départ des prochaines
il y avait beaucoup de viande
à côté d'une arène où il y a des
taureaux qui sont embrochés
ça vous dégoûte quand vous voyez ça
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
ressentez en fait
j'y suis un peu habitué je je
je ne ressens rien en réalité je
sinon j'ai pas fini d'être malheureux
je comprends mais en colère parce que
c'est un combat aussi politique
maintenant
que j'ai publiquement c'est longtemps
été effectivement végétarien dans dans
une sphère purement personnelle j'en
parlais pas autour de moi j'en parlais
pas à mes collègues et puis il se trouve
qu'un jour j'ai sorti un livre sur le
sujet parce que j'ai expliqué pourquoi
selon moi
la consommation de viande était une
hérésie pour des raisons sanitaires pour
des raisons écologiques pour des raisons
philosophiques bon et il se trouve que
c'est quasiment un sujet journalistique
pour moi quand je l'ai sorti mais de
fait ça m'a rendu engagé sur ces
questions publiquement et depuis c'est
vrai que j'ai j'assume complètement la
question vous essayez forcément on a vu
dans le sujet je ne suis pas en colère
vous vous demandez si je suis en colère
je suis pas en colère j'ai pas envie de
me battre avec des gens qui m'engoient
pas du tout je comprends de voir des
gens
je suis pas attristé
la France est un pays où on a habitué
depuis trois quatre générations les gens
parce que pendant longtemps on n'a pas
mangé beaucoup de viande en réalité
simplement depuis l'après-guerre depuis
des années 60-70 en réalité que l'avion
des devenus l'élément principal de tous
les repas en France qui était pas du
tout le cas avant donc aujourd'hui on a
habitué trois quatre générations à
manger de la viande en leur faisant
croire que cette viande est absolument
indispensable à leur santé tout comme
les produits laitiers les campagnes
depuis qu'on a eu des produits
que j'ai pu sortir
a pas vraiment imprimer là on entend
quelqu'un qui dit moi je mange de la
viande
Jean-Pierre là il y a une dame qui dit
67 millions de Français vous pensez que
mes livres ont le pouvoir de changer de
régimentaire de 67 millions de personnes
non en revanche vous ne pouvez pas nier
que et pas pas mes livres mais pas
comédie mais il y a quand même beaucoup
d'acteurs aujourd'hui qui qui sur la
table vous paniez quand même qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une évolution des mentalités
vous le savez très bien qu'il y a une
diminution de la consommation de viande
notamment de la diminution de la
consommation de viande rouge donc il
commence à avoir un changement
d'habitude qui dit le contraire moi de
l'ONU pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture consommation de viande qui
devrait encore augmenter dans le monde
15% elle va doubler 2030
la consommation viande si on ne change
pas parler de la France
en 2021 c'est le dernier chiffre connu
ça fait légèrement baissé les deux trois
années précédentes non ça c'est la
viande totale c'est pas que l'avion
rouge
et plus de viande blanche d'accord
baisse par contre la viande ce qu'on
appelle la viande blanche augmente mais
dans le monde c'est un mouvement alors
que vous nous parliez d'exemple à
l'étranger ce sont des pays qu'on
appelle qu'on appelait on voit le
développement les pays émergents qui eux
consomment de plus en plus de viande
c'est à dire que la plupart d'achat qui
augmente légèrement l'élevage intensif
les élevages industriels se développent
absolument partout c'est ce qui fait et
c'est le problème qui explique que nous
devons justement vraiment penser la
question de la consommation de la viande
parce que vous avez raison de souligner
que si on ne fait rien et bien
effectivement la consommation aura
doublé d'ici 2050 dans le monde or la
planète n'est pas capable de soutenir
autant d'élevage la planète elle a déjà
quand même beaucoup de beaucoup de
problèmes la viande c'est 15% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
80% de la destruction de la forêt
amazonienne c'est la pollution des
nappes phréatiques enfin il y a
énormément de problèmes moi je suis
c'est prêt en priorité vegan pour des
raisons éthiques et morales mais la
question environnementale elle est
essentielle c'est à dire que même si
vous considérez que c'est pas grave on
peut tuer des animaux le fait que on ne
peut plus continuer à consommer autant
de viande qu'on le fait aujourd'hui il y
a quelque chose que je comprends pas
très bien dans votre engagement vous
êtes antispé si cette vegan vous
soutenez des associations comme L214
comme peut-être ceux qui s'en prennent
aux boucheries je ne sais pas enfin non
non enfin en tout cas des associations
comme L214 qui veulent mettre fin à
l'élevage c'est votre objectif et en
même temps vous dites moi j'ai de la
tolérance pour ceux qui mangent de la
viande et est-ce qu'il y a pas un double
Emerica en fait c'est parce que je pense
qu'on est dans une société qui attend
des gens qui faisaient des positions
caricaturales et je pense que c'est ce
qu'on va dans le système médiatique sur
tout un tas de sujets aujourd'hui avec
des personnalités qui émergent avec des
positions qui sont très clivantes et qui
empêche toute forme et qui empêche et
qui et qui empêche et qui empêche
pardonnez-moi toutes formes de dialogue
j'ai toujours
prôner cette essentiel pour moi de
discuter et de convaincre et non pas
d'exclure je n'exclurai jamais quelqu'un
qui mange de la viande je vais essayer
de j'essaie de convaincre j'adore ça
essayer de convaincre et cette personne
n'est pas convaincue tant pis je crois
fortement la démocratie quand j'entends
des gens qui disent on veut pas me
forcer à arrêter de manger de la viande
personne parle de forcer à athénogènes
en revanche peut-être que vous vous
mangerez la viande jusqu'à la fin de vos
jours mais peut-être que peut-être que
vos enfants vont être touchés par les
arguments que qu'on peut entendre à
droite à gauche pour baisser la
consommation ou pour arrêter carrément
les animaux et c'est ça ce à quoi moi
j'essaye de participer très modestement
c'est à dire un changement des
consciences mais je veux le faire par la
persuasion et par le dialogue dans votre
portrait il y avait écrit anarchiste et
pour la désobéissance civile c'est vrai
ça ou pas alors moi c'est ce que j'ai lu
sur lui on peut croire en la démocratie
et néanmoins avoir un fond profondément
anarchiste c'est-à-dire se méfier de
l'État tel qu'il fonctionne aujourd'hui
prenez liberté maximale des individus
la désobéissance huile très importante
bien sûr
ne pas payer ses impôts pourquoi pas
pour protester contre un gouvernement ou
contre une mesure en particulier ce qui
avait fait taureau par exemple à
l'époque
ça c'est des choses extraordinaires la
désobéissance civile à la Gandhi enfin
c'est une manière de faire de la
politique très pacifique aymeric Caron
j'ai une question quand vous dites zéro
viande que effectivement vous dites que
le monde ne sera pas supporter mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites de l'élevage
est-ce qu'il n'y aura plus dans le monde
que vous imaginez pour sauver la planète
je dis pas que c'est le monde aimerait
40 parce que ça lui fait plaisir vous
avez effectivement vous dites c'est des
conditions environnementales qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de l'élevage dans l'arête
d'abord mais ça veut dire que dans un
pays il n'y a plus de vache plus d'abord
parce que je suis sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire je suis député donc je
tiens aussi ceux qui ont voté pour moi
je représente le problème de la nuit
Pesse qui ne prévoit pas du tout
d'arrêter l'élevage ah bah voilà
vers une agriculture qui soit purement
végétale c'est à dire que donc
qu'il fasse des céréales fin des légumes
des fruits enfin voilà tout ce qui
permet de nourrir l'humanité en pleine
transition est-ce qu'elle passe par
exemple il y a une ville au Pays-Bas qui
est interdit la publicité pour la viande
est-ce que vous vous trouvez par exemple
on devrait suivre ce chemin-là qu'il
faut que je suis pour une limitation
très forte de la publicité en général ça
tombe bah oui bah oui parce que
l'un des problèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est un problème de surconsommation
quel que soit les produits
là ce dont on parle c'est bien une
interdiction des publicités non c'est
pas député pour arrêter de manger de la
viande là c'est c'est bien là ce dont
vous parlez au Pays-Bas si je ne me
trompe c'est ils n'ont plus le droit
dans cette ville d'afficher des
publicités pour la viande voilà donc
c'est bien on limite déjà une forme de
publicité donc pour inciter des gens à
acheter et oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est
c'est délétère en tout cas c'est
contre-productif c'est irresponsable
tout simplement que d'inciter des gens à
manger plus de viande puisque c'est
exactement l'inverse qu'il faut faire
pour le bien de la planète donc ça me
paraît pas incohérent du tout si on
revient sur la polémique barbecue initié
par Sandrine Rousseau est-ce que vous
pour vous le barbecue il est les gens
intéressante ah ben je ne sais pas je ne
sais plus comment elle est dans votre
partie enfin dans la Nupe dans votre
groupe intergroupe on pourrait dire moi
je fais partie du groupe France
insoumise vous les rappeler mon parti
c'est l'arrêt révolution écologique pour
le violon
en tout cas
honnêtement c'est pas normal qu'un sujet
comme ça fasse une semaine 15 jours et
même que un mois après on en reparle si
on veut interroger je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure est-ce que oui la viande
barbecue pas barbecue on s'en fiche
est-ce que la viande a été associée à
des valeurs de virilité oui mais
évidemment bien sûr je l'explique dans
deux steaks un livre que j'ai écrit en
ce moment il y a des études qui ont été
faites mais bien évidemment un sujet
derrière le barbecue c'est une non c'est
une image c'est une le problème c'est la
meilleure dont on en parle moi je veux
bien je voudrais qu'on élargisse le
sujet dans ce cas-là et que on parle on
fait des débats sur la mythologie de la
viande mais il y a pas que le
masculinité il y a plein d'autres
mythologies par exemple faut manger de
la viande pour être en forme c'est
là-dedans qu'on trouve les protéines non
on démonte tout on va expliquer que dans
les légumineuses dans les céréales on
trouve des protéines on va je voudrais
qu'on ait un vrai débat sur les mythe de
la viande mais vous êtes quand même
d'accord peut-être
les femmes mangent plus de viande que
les études le montrent je ne sais pas où
en sommes aujourd'hui et ça m'intéresse
peu c'est vraiment pas mon sujet ma
question aujourd'hui c'est est-ce
comment on traite les animaux qu'on
mange est-ce un peu s'il vous plaît les
traiter un petit peu mieux on finir avec
les élevages industriels et puis ensuite
se poser la question de savoir si on a
vraiment besoin ou pas de les manger
savoir ce sont des hommes ou des femmes
qui mangent c'est vraiment pas mon souci
principal vous allez déposer une
proposition de loi pour interdire
l'élevage industriel dans quelle
profession
en effet du poème de la France insoumise
j'espère qu'on pourra effectivement
déposer une proposition de loi
prochainement sur ce sujet on en parle
avec d'autres collègues députés moi pour
l'instant je suis occupé par une autre
proposition de loi extrêmement
importantes qui est effectivement
interdire la Corée elle est déjà
interdite qui vise en fait à rendre la
loi cohérente puisque la corrida est
interdite en France
et qu'il y a une exception à la loi qui
est faite pour quelques départements
donc je voudrais simplement que la loi
française s'applique sur tout le
territoire vous pensez obtenir gain de
cause récupérer des les voix suffisantes
pour faire voter cette proposition de
loi
je ne peux pas imaginer qu'il en soit
autrement pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
lorsque vous regardez les sondages 8 à 9
Français sur 10 souhaitent
l'interdiction de la corrida avec mise à
mort donc avec torture et mise à mort 8
à 9 Français sur 10 or nous les députés
on est des représentants de la volonté
populaire donc il faut mettre la loi en
conformité avec la volonté populaire sur
ce sujet d'autre part si jamais il y a
vraiment huit à neuf Français sur 10 et
bien sûr c'est vrai qui sont aujourd'hui
opposés de la corrida ça veut dire que
l'assemblée qui je l'espère et sans
cesse être assez représentatif du peuple
doit contenir aussi une majorité de
députés opposés à corrida je ne pourrais
pas imaginer qu'il y a un tel
différentiel entre 9 Français sur 10
dans le Pinot puis qu'elle assemblé non
il est 75% de députés favorable ce n'est
pas possible ça veut donc dire que
ce qu'on attend député c'est qu'il vote
aussi en son âme et conscience et donc
j'attends de mes collègues députés
qu'ils disent avec franchise sincérité
ce qu'il pense de cette séance de
torture médiatisée est-ce que oui ou non
on autorise quelle continuité dans ce
pays et quel est le message aussi qu'ils
veulent donner de notre République et
des valeurs que l'on souhaite que cette
république est-ce que la torture d'un
animal légalisée ça fait partie d'une
République que l'on souhaite je ne le
crois pas donc je ne peux pas imaginer
je ne peux pas imaginer tout simplement
qu'il est une majorité de députés qui
vote contre cette proposition de loi et
elle passera au mois de novembre
je suis pas le seul à le dire c'est si
jamais ça passe pas historique parce que
d'abord il y a eu plusieurs propositions
de loi qui ont déjà été écrite mais qui
n'ont jamais été débattus dans
l'hémicycle donc ça ce sera une première
serait historique parce que ça fait
longtemps quand même qu'il y a des gens
qui veulent la bouillir la corrida qui
ne sont pas parvenus en raison de
pression de lobby et en raison aussi de
la lâcheté des élus il faut le dire et
là je je suis confiant dans le fait que
ils seront pas là je mes collègues de
tous les partis politiques et ce serait
historique parce que ça donnera un signe
extrêmement fort pour le reste de la
lutte qui est encore énorme pour les
droits des animaux dans ce pays il y a
pas beaucoup d'animaux ont été qui sont
concernés par par la corrida en terme
d'individus c'est un millier de taux à
peu près qui sont sacrifiés en
France.com apparent on peut dire bon
c'est pas énorme ici il y a peut-être
d'autres domaines où il y a beaucoup
plus d'animaux la chasse l'élevage
industriels etc mais symboliquement en
revanche il y a un verrou qui sauterait
alors vous connaissez sûrement les
darkstors puisque vous êtes élus de
Paris ils ont poussé comme des
champignons et dans quelques autres
grandes villes aussi alors effet de mode
ou nouvelle habitude de consommation et
avec quelles conséquences pour les
riverains on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte on a vu sur GIR avec le
covid un souvenez-vous les Dark kitchen
et ces restaurants sont rentables qui
font 100% de livraison voici maintenant
que débarquent dans les centres villes
c'est dark store des magasins fantômes
qui livrent à domicile sous la pression
des riverains les pouvoirs publics
contre-attaquent en faisant la chasse à
ces entrepôts qui sont hors la loi dans
les centres-villes c'est une enquête
d'Hélène Bonduelle de jeunes cutins et
de clés à jouado
une bouteille de lait une boîte de
mouchoirs des fruits en quelques clics
ces applications vous promettent une
livraison de vos courses en un temps
record
à l'autre bout de la chaîne c'est locaux
sans vitrine nichés discrètement au pied
d'immeubles d'habitation ce sont ce
qu'on appelle des Dark store des
entrepôts fantômes c'est vraiment une
nouvelle forme de vente qu'on n'avait
jamais vu jusqu'à présent et c'est la
question en effet de la livraison du
dernier kilomètre c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut comme pour tenir leur promesse de
vous livrer en 10 minutes ou à un quart
d'heure il faut qu'il soit au plus
proche de chez vous en plein
centre-ville donc à l'intérieur pas de
clients mais des rayonnages de denrées
alimentaires d'hygiène et dehors un
balai incessant de livreur à vélo ou en
scooter et dérivera excédés par ces
allées et venus tout le quartier a eu
Asplin depuis que le Dark Store est
installé de énormément de nuisances
d'abord sonore mais aussi d'incivilité
de déliroutiers emprunter la rue en sens
interdit parce que ça fait un raccourci
pour le livreur une centaine de Dark
Store se sont ainsi implantées dans la
capitale 80% de manière illégale car la
ville interdit l'installation
d'anthropologie
d'immeubles d'habitation
Samira en fait les frais depuis un an le
Dark sort est juste en face donc c'est
ce qu'on voit depuis mon balcon et ce
sont des nuisances 7 jours sur 7 ce
jour-là l'activité est calme mais voici
ce qui se passe à la tombée de la nuit
ça va être des livraisons de poids
lourds qui vont livrer donc et décharger
en plein milieu de la voie publique des
livreurs qui vont rester à attendre
leurs commandes devant sur leur
téléphone en parlant fort sur
haut-parleur jusqu'à minuit une
cohabitation devenue impossible à
contrôler aussi pour les mères ça c'est
tous les jours il réclame ton
gouvernement depuis des mois de pouvoir
réguler ses activités sans être dans
l'interdiction pure et dure aujourd'hui
c'est un phénomène qui existe il faut
juste le réguler il y a des endroits où
ça peut être adapté en périphérie où il
y a pas d'habitation où on a une
plateforme un peu plus logistique là
franchement c'est pas possible de
laisser ce type d'entrepôts prospérer
dans nos vies le gouvernement a tenté de
légaliser ses commerces avant de
rétropédaler un décret est en cours
d'écriture qui les classifie comme
entrepôt logistique il donnera aussi la
possibilité aux maires de décider de
leur installation la mairie de Paris
vient un tel aussi de durcir le bras de
fer avec les darkstore on l'a attendu la
main il y a maintenant un an au Dar
Store en leur disant ne vous installez
pas n'importe où venez discuter on peut
vous aider aujourd'hui on est passé dans
un mode beaucoup plus coercitif à la
fois avec des amendes qui commencent
cette semaine et puis par des procédures
judiciaires pour les obliger à fermer
cinq Darksters Parisiens ont été
contrôlés fin septembre par la police 4
ont aussi reçu des contraventions pour
installation illégales aucune des
sociétés incriminées à accepter
d'interview mais certaines ont déjà
commencé à fermer des entrepôts signe
peut-être que le vent tourne
aimerait 40 on voulait interdire les
corridas l'élevage intensif je
m'avançais un peu mais aussi interdire
les les darkstore je pense que les
interdire ce qui a été dit dans le sujet
me semblait assez sage il s'agit la
réglementer
là le problème c'est qu'on a
effectivement des commerces qui se
déroulent dans des endroits qui ne sont
pas faits pour ça donc qui sont hors
législation
ensuite avec les nuisances qui peuvent
être décrites pour pour les riverains
donc tout ça ça va pas évidemment qu'il
faut il faut mettre tout ça à plat moi
il y a un autre problème qui me qui me
gêne terriblement c'est l'exploitation
des salariés
parce que les conditions de travail bien
évidemment des livres sont terribles on
les connaît sont pas des salariés des
Dark stores les livreurs sont souvent
des des petites sociétés
dans le cas présent vous avez tout à
fait raison donc voilà les conditions de
travail de ceux qui qui libres qui sont
bien sûr scandaleuses ensuite il y a
toute une philosophie de vie aussi
derrière de la part des consommateurs
c'est à dire que si jamais ces magasins
x parce qu'il y a quand même des gens
qui les utilisent donc est-ce que oui ou
non par exemple il faut pas plutôt les
interdire non non c'est pour ça que
j'aime que les sujets soient traités
vraiment par plusieurs angles c'est à
dire c'est ça je n'aime pas ce qui est
binaire c'est pour tes contre c'est bien
c'est mal non non mais d'abord je mets
un peu la liste effectivement de tous
les problèmes que ça pose je pense que
est-ce que tiens on a plus de persil
est-ce que vraiment on clique sur un
ordinateur parce qu'il est 22h j'ai plus
de persil je clique je vais venir
quelqu'un sur un vélo pour m'apporter
non je crois le droit à la paresse non
ah vous me provoquer parce que
il y aurait des choses à dire très
intéressantes sur le droit à la paresse
mais là encore pas du tout ce qu'il y en
a été dit médiatiquement parce que on va
pas sortir de chez soi puis faire venir
les livreurs pour la pizza pour le film
etc c'est aussi un peu plus souvent
on peut l'envisager autrement donc voilà
je pense qu'à un moment il faut que les
consommateurs soient raisonnables et qui
provoquent pas l'émergence de genre de
billets ensuite il faut reconnaître
quand même que moi quand j'entends dire
mets ton lait en périphérie on peut se
poser la question de l'écologie le fait
qu'il y ait des produits qui soient
rapidement disponibles et faire les
mettre en périphérie serait une mauvaise
idée parce qu'en réalité
les produits auraient beaucoup plus de
chemin à faire individuellement pour
aller chez l'un chez l'autre alors qu'en
effet ils sont dans un centurbain
écologiquement effectivement le produit
fait un peu moins de chemin donc l'idée
qu'il y ait des endroits où on puisse se
faire livrer pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
avec une réglementation précise avec des
employés
plus adapté qui est des vrais contrats
de travail qui soient dignement avec des
horaires qu'on fixe c'est-à-dire que on
dit allez la nuit par exemple pas la
nuit c'est comme ça on fera avec la nuit
on peut pas acheter un produit c'est pas
parce que le livre que c'est pas très
grave entre 9h et 18h 19h 20h voilà je
pense qu'à ces solutions et bien
évidemment en étudiant des lieux
adéquats on fait pas ça par exemple dans
des dans des appartements à côté des
écoles là les images collectées par
Hélène sont incroyables les vidéos c'est
pour ça que on a les moyens de faire
appliquer justement cette loi qui va
arriver soit c'est un décret en fait tu
vas passer parce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut mettre plus de policiers pour
interdire
bien évidemment c'est comme les lois si
on reprend le sujet sur hier vous savez
il y a eu cet amendement qui est passé
qu'on devra discuter ensuite dans
l'hémicycle pour
pour
déduction d'impôts
qui s'introduisent aujourd'hui parfois
dans des abattoirs c'est parce qu'elles
font le travail que malheureusement
l'état ne fait pas ça se travaille de
surveillance avec des gens qui vont
inspecter que en effet la loi est bien
respectée vous êtes en train de dire
pour les derstore on aurait un petit peu
le même il y en a pas donc il y en a pas
assez pour pour les élevages des
abattoirs vous avez raison de dire on
est resté sans doute le même problème
bien sûr mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
du coup on fait pas passer le décret
parce que on n'est pas sûr et certain on
va pas mettre des policiers non plus
dans chaque rue c'est absolument
impossible et vous le disiez tout à
l'heure le consommateur il est un peu
schizophrène en fait ce que il veut
avoir tout en 15 minutes et en même
temps il est gêné par les nuisances
sonores etc c'est c'est une vraie
responsabilité individuelle aussi mais
évidemment il faut bien voir qu'on sort
quand même de 30 années à peu près ou 40
années d'hyper égoïsme on a tous
considéré ou beaucoup d'entre nous ont
considéré que nous avions le droit parce
que c'est la société néolibérale qui
nous a dit que c'était comme ça nous
avons le droit de demander tout ce que
nous voulions et de l'obtenir
immédiatement à partir du moment où on
le payait c'est de ça juste ce
corollaire ce qu'il va y avoir de
l'argent en face pour avoir le service
en question donc l'éthique la morale qui
pour moi sont des valeurs essentielles
qui sont un peu
on va dire hormone aujourd'hui des modes
moi je crois qu'il faut les remettre au
centre du débat bien sûr qu'on a tous
une responsabilité
comme on est responsabilité dans la
manière dont on se comporte les uns avec
les autres dans la vie quotidienne la
manière dont on parle aux gens la
manière dont on va parler d'ailleurs à
je pas à quelqu'un un employé dans un
magasin etc la même manière ce qu'on
achète ce qu'on consomme bien sûr c'est
pas quelque chose qui est anodin ça
parle de nous et ça parle du monde ça
parle du monde que l'on veut que l'on
veut la sobriété bien sûr
j'ai j'ai
comment dirais j'ai milité je milite en
effet pour une société moi je n'hésite
pas employer le mot de décroissance
c'est un mot là encore qui est tabou qui
est là encore pas bien compris mais la
France vous savez très bien que si
l'ensemble de la planète vivait comme
comme les Français il nous faudrait
trois planètes
si l'ensemble la planète vivait comme
les États-Unis il faudrait 5 planètes ça
veut donc dire qu'il y a un problème ça
veut donc dire c'est aussi simple que ça
que on consomme trop on achète trop de
choses on se déplace trop parfois de
manière inutile donc faut s'y réfléchir
à d'autres manières de vivre le
télétravail peut être là par exemple une
option sur les transports on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir
20 jeans dans son dans son armoire
d'avoir 30 vestes c'est complètement
inutile alors bien sûr en disant ça
c'est très gênant puisque qu'est-ce
qu'on est en train d'écrire rien qu'en
disant cela un nouveau modèle politique
économique fini les les magasins styles
Zara etc avec des collections qui
changent tous les deux mois avec des
vêtements travaillés plutôt fabriqués
dans des pays où là encore les
travailleurs sont mal payés on arrête
tout ça
on fait on fait beaucoup moins et on
fait mieux c'est comme d'ailleurs le
travail la réduction du temps de travail
on travaille un peu moins mais ce n'est
plus quatre jours je vous propose qu'on
passe au dessert c'est le péché mignon
et un dessert régressif choisi par notre
invité aimerait Caron une mousse au
chocolat mais il y a pas des fraises
tagada
mais il y a un mais parce que c'est pas
une mousse avec des œufs montés en neige
mais elle est quand même mousseuse donc
il y a une petite recette c'est sans
doute j'ai pas demandé à chez Françoise
qui m'a fourni mais c'est sans doute de
l'eau de pois chiches monté au batteur
comme ça alors ensuite il y a pas de
beurre il y a rien on va la goûter
est-ce qu'elle est est-ce qu'elle est
bonne c'est une très bonne elle est très
bonne est-ce qu'elle est meilleure
qu'une mousse au chocolat avec des œufs
et du beurre quand vous si vous en
souvenez encore dans votre enfance quand
vous mangez de ces mousses au chocolat
chez votre grand-mère
elle est un peu différente sans doute
le goût j'imagine puisqu'il y a pas tout
à fait les mêmes ingrédients il y a
forcément pas tout à fait le même goût
mais je vais vous dire là encore joueur
pas de l'éducation au goût en ce moment
c'est pas mauvaise hein
parce que je suis très heureux parce que
il y a plein de nouvelles marques de
fromage vegan qui viennent de sortir
alors c'est extraordinaire des
camemberts vegan c'est pas fait du lait
de vache c'est pas fait du lait de
brebis pour camembert il y a pas des
chèvres bref c'est autre chose notamment
les noix de cajou etc mais alors c'est
excellent et qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est que je suis en train de
redécouvrir le plaisir de manger un
fromage qui n'est pas le même fromage
que je mangeais quand j'avais 15 ou 20
ans
regardez l'ironie là le petit mouvement
de sourcils mais non mais les fromagers
le foie gras non mais ça par contre ça
pourra faire partie de mon travail à
l'Assemblée
là encore c'est de la torture de la
barbarie absolument inutile vous vous
avez pas dit mais vous vous
cuisez ou sucré
des
desserts j'ai fait ça pour une émission
de télévision
ou effectivement j'ai utilisé du jus de
pois chiche pas mal ça marche bien ça
marche très bien mais non mais j'ai la
chance d'avoir une compagne qui cuisine
extrêmement bien alors oh là là
j'entends déjà des commentaires mon dieu
c'est pas lui qui cuisine mais elle
adore que c'est une excellente cuisine
dans la même non mais c'est une
excellente cuisinière est-ce qu'elle
fait et d'ailleurs elle m'a elle-même
redonné enfin je mangeais déjà un puit
vegan voilà parce que je me débrouillais
ma belle vraiment j'ai redécouvert des
plaisirs
gustatif parce que elle elle sait
absolument tout accommodée et c'est
vraiment très bon donc je dois avouer
que c'est vrai quelle cuisine beaucoup
plus que moi et que moi ce que je fais
et très très sommaire très très c'est
quoi votre la signature quand aymeric
Caron se met au fourneau de légumes ça
j'adore faire des fricassée de légumes
dans lesquels je vais ajouter du tofu
dans lesquels je mets avant tout les
légumes que je que je que se trouve
notamment des poivrons j'adore les
poivrons donc les champignons je suis un
fan absolu de de champignons et des
cèpes en ce moment ou des
c'est mon péché mignon voilà ça va être
des choses très simples basiques un peu
quand Jean-Pierre a dit c'est régressif
le chocolat c'est pas un goût de sucre
le chocolat que ça c'est chimique
au sens que c'est un peu un dessert de
notre enfance la mousse au chocolat même
si elle est souvent à la table des
bracelets encore mais oui c'est pour ça
que je disais ça j'étais étonné parce
qu'il y a des desserts qui qu'on peut
qualifier de régressif en effet même le
chocolat je n'avais pas vu comme ça
je suis très très chocolat tous les
jours j'ai besoin d'avoir ma dose de
chocolat mais effectivement si là pour
être clair et pour être objectif s'il y
a du très bon chocolat c'est pas trop
sucré on oublie complètement le jus de
pois chiche on oublie qu'il y a pas des
œufs en neige et effectivement
en question de texture je l'aurais
reconnu mais en question de goût c'est
tout à fait acceptable mais on peut se
régaler avec vegan pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à table sur LCP